Cacti and desert beetles can live in arid
environments because they’ve adapted to
suck water out of the air.
So, can we do that if we’re in a drought?
Hi guys, Amy here for DNews.
We know the Earth’s climate is warming from
a mix of natural changes, including solar
activity, and man-made causes, namely greenhouse
gases and aerosols.
This is taking a toll on global weather.
There is more water vapour in the atmosphere
so rainfall is increasing in tropical areas,
but drier areas are experiencing some of the
worst droughts in history.
The thing is, even in deserts, there's humidity
in the air.
So, to help tackle the world's drought problems,
a team of scientists from Harvard, with support
from the Department of Energy, looked to plants
and insects that are able to pull water out
of the air to survive in the desert.
This biologically-inspired technology described
in the journal Nature involves collecting
water from air by condensing water vapor on
surfaces inspired by beetles, cacti and other
desert-dwelling organisms.
They looked at the bumpy surfaces of desert
beetles’ shells and found that, if the geometry
is right, water droplets grow faster on the
tops of convex bumps than on a raised flat
surface of the same height.
They looked at the asymmetric structure of
cactus spines and found they had the best
topography to guide the condensation off the
bumps to be collected.
And, the slippery surface of carnivorous pitcher
plants inspired the researches to guide those
formed water droplets down a smooth, non-stick
surface.
The team combined these elements with a material
that repels liquid called Slippery Liquid-Infused
Porous Surfaces technology or SLIPS.
The three nature-inspired inventions combined
with the SLIPS technology make an excellent
collector to gather water from the air!
When set up, any atmospheric moisture pools
on the bumps and flows as water droplets down
the asymmetrically pitted water-repellant
surface!
But could it make a difference?
I asked the paper’s lead author Kenneth
Park.
He roughly calculates that the volume of air
the size of a house in a desert holds about
16 liters of water.
That’s not a lot for people in developed
countries, but in desert regions it could
be life changing access to drinking and cooking
water.
And of course in humid areas, that number
rises even more.
Basically, as long as surface temperature
gets below the dew point, there will be condensation
to harness from the air.
The challenge now facing the team is controlling
the size of the water droplets and the direction
in which they flow.
But with the details worked out, this could
be a step towards developing a passive system
capable of collecting and transporting atmospheric
water to a reservoir.
But remember, while this technology is great,
it’s a proof of concept.
We still need to conserve resources, especially
those of us living in areas affected by drought,
like California, which is experiencing the
worst drought in more than a century.
So with scientists developing these kinds
of technologies, just how serious is the global
drought that we’re looking to thin air as
a water source?
Julia’s got the information on this current
crisis in this episode right here.
Some people are creeped out drinking recycled
water… would you feel weird drinking water
full from the air?
Let us know in the comments and don’t forget
to subscribe so you never miss an episode
of DNews.